in our previous video we looked at how
enable broadening and disable keyword
search can help you adjust the number of
jobs that are returned from a search
let's talk about two more options
featured jobs and custom ranking to
further influence your search results
[Music]
first up you have the ability to feature
a job by setting a promotion value this
is a property actually attached to each
individual job posting when performing a
search request against the API you can
filter if you want only feature jobs to
be returned
using featured jobs allows you to
highlight jobs that are important in
terms of your business needs any
featured jobs are returned an order of
promotion value if multiple jobs have
the same promotion value the relevance
of the job listing is used as a
tiebreaker however it's important to
balance not only how you're showing
featured jobs but also ensuring the
relevance of search results if you only
show featured jobs are ordered by your
promotion value you may not be returning
the highest quality matches for a search
request this means that the user may not
be exactly seeing the best experience
and could have lower engagement so it's
important to balance your implementation
with the number and presentation of
featured jobs also when searching for
future jobs you can use enable
broadening so you have expanded query
results that come back when doing a
search request one important note is
that we recommend not using featured
jobs when disabled keyword match is set
to false this can lead to a featured job
being promoted when it could be fairly
irrelevant to the users query for
example if you featured a job for a
software engineer with a server
administration in the description and
someone searches for a restaurant server
they may see this software engineering
job as the top match with keyword
matching this job fits the criteria and
coupled with being featured it might end
up towards the top and provide a poor
experience for the user again it's
important to make sure the configuration
makes sense for your use cases and that
you test to get the best results
featured jobs lets you split off certain
jobs to be returned separately but you
can also use custom ranking to influence
the order in which jobs are returned
custom ranking can be done through an
expression where you create a formula to
influence the ordering of results these
formulas can involve simple math and
custom attributes for jobs which we'll
talk a bit more about in the next video
when setting a custom ranking formula
the jobs in the search result will get
returned
according to your formula giving you
more control over ordering them based on
the way you want jobs to return and to
keep job search results relevant you
should use featured jobs or custom
ranking however we don't really
recommend using both at the same time
they're both powerful tools to give you
the customization support to meet your
business logic but there are two ways of
solving the same problem so using them
at the same time can be hard to manage
and give confusing results for your
users featured jobs and custom ranking
along with broadening and keyword
matching are major ways to configure and
tweak the results that come back from
the job search API in our next video
we'll look at some more configuration
options that are a bit smaller and best
practice is to keep in mind when you're
testing out your integration thanks for
watching and remember when looking for
talent it's okay to keep your head in
the cloud